The Walking Dead, c'est l'histoire d'un mec
qui a pas beaucoup de chance dans la vie. En gros.
Même pas du tout en fait mais bon déjà il se fait tirer dessus
Quand il se réveille de son coma la quasi totalité de la population s'est transformée en zombies
A partir de là, on se dit que niveau chance dans la vie on a fait mieux , on a fait bien mieux.
Ca sert à rien qu'il joue au loto ou qu'il s'achète un morpion le mec
Gardes tes sous.
Et en bonus le mec est shérif en Géorgie
Ca va dire qu'il est obligé de porter ce chapeau RIDICULE toute l'année !
Toute l'année ! Ce truc sur la tête !
Ce mec cède pas en plus
Je préfère me faire manger par un zombie.
"Votre chapeau et vous êtes officiellement shérif"
Ca ! Sur ma tête !
"C'est ça"
Oh non non non ! Pas du tout ! Impossible !
Même pour une soirée déguisée
Je trouve ça ringard
Je m'en fous, appelez un zombie
Transformez moi en chipolata, j'm'en bats les c*******
Moi vivant, jamais !
Mort vivant j'dis pas !
Ca je sais pas.
Et quand l'espèce est en train de se transformer en morts vivants
Et que tu es le repas le plus recherché du continent.
Qu'est que tu fais ? Réflexe vital. C'est normal
Tu vas te réfugier dans un endroit où il n'y a absolument personne.
Un endroit totalement désert.
Sur Google + par exemple
Mais non ! Le héros qu'est-ce qu'il fout ? Il va dans une ville !
La où la concentration de zombies est la plus importante !
C'est comme si un poulet allait se réfugier dans un KFC.
Espérance de vie : 14 secondes
14 secondes le poulet hop !  Nuggets ! Terminé.
Et le pire to pire lol
Quel est son moyen de locomotion pour aller dans cette ville ?
Un cheval.
Qu'il est con !
Comment tu fais pour fermer les portières quand une bande de zombies t'attaquent !
Tu peux pas ! Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'un cheval n'a pas de portières
Et c'est normal ! Puisque c'est un cheval !
Enfin bref. The Walking Dead c'est une bonne série de zombies. Voilà
.
Qu'il l'est pas à moitié.
(yaaaarrrrr)
Sauf pour elle comme elle est moitié de..
Voilà. Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager.
Et laissez un commentaire si vous voulez que je parle d'une autre série la prochaine fois.
C'est bon vous pouvez circuler.